NASA believes they may have found
primitive alien life
on Saturn's moon Titan that's right they
sent their spacecraft
cassini up over there and the analyte
the chemistry
a blue moon service ima take a look at
what they found tightening the only mood
around Saturn with the dent atmosphere
that could sustain life
we and the way we know it at two papers
that publish these findings by nasa
claim that
hydrogen gas from the atmosphere
disappears at the moon surface
suggesting that thumping is breathing it
in
boot camp like the movie that sounds
like a hacer sounds like something that
I am to my first question every time we
do anything on aliens
I always ask this first when the aliens
come mmm
will be a killer story members and then
look at all why are they the aliens
while we read
one they're coming from a ship then
they're the area that I S
right but but when the aliens to bed
great okay leon is gonna Kelly so in
that case maybe we'll tell each other
you think there's any chance pilot
brothers all %uh
yeah football team up with their alien
technology get really cold
yeah maybe you think that I think I
guess whoever would be the alien would
be the one that's going right so if we
go there
yeah and we try to join their mind what
was on my job better
where the airline I mean I don't mean to
sound like a sci-fi
not goodnight oye I think I've always
thought it was a little
problematic that work keep beaming this
Singhal
saying hey we're here if you want to
find us were here like
why are we telling the rest of the
galaxy that we are on a planet that's
has I can sustain life for me
I don't wanna selling another Metallica
not know if I like the little one real
world in their own alien that's gonna
come down rather not gonna come down to
just have it like scientific experiment
clearly there floating around the
universe looking for another planet to
inhabit so why wouldn't they just a
clear sound so that just using the logic
up what we're doing here we know where
that at some point we're gonna destroy
the earth and that's why they're trying
to them
you know we're trying to stop on mars
when we discovered America who was in
just to say like oh hey I got
what's going on you're going to see how
that then we wiped them out but you're
basically these are
these are human instincts that you're
basing this on
show I don't think anybody was going to
help you unless it's the cloud
I alien from the gas alien from tight I
don't think he is a threat to us the
cloud one
yeah you think basically someone
discovers or some some life one
discovers are
that their for the first thing I'll do
it to taped a ghetto
I think it's a I think it's a chance
vietnam the one we don't arrest year
you're a you I mean you smoke but I
liked that I'm in fact that pretty much
I've come up with my theory that the
other members are
paranoia plus sci-fi hey I have a
hundred don't owe more on this planet
right yeah I mean what is it that today
yeah in then kinda the Avatar
hearing that that's what happen in the
movie Avatar you know we went there cuz
we wanted their natural resources right
because we had already plummeted are I
based mine on a scientific research not
just watching Avatar why does it matter
I read a book while
comic but one says really haha K not
right in saying I can't know that helped
yeah
number really assess slightly joking
aside is there any chance
if alien life he'd come here is there
any chance we ultimately wouldn't wanna
kill it or or it now killer
go way we do everything because you said
human instinct argument is it worth of
prey to what we don't know we're afraid
what we don't know that lives on the
other side the cracks in the same tell
me you know what love
if it happens it happens I just mean I
can't I
everybody can be my I give it up round I
don't wanna like
think about killing something else for
finding something else I mean
back now nothing want to kill me that
and the fact that when a German
you know I its I just can't yeah its I
want them
I didn't have such a federal offense in
this yeah I just don't wanna live like
I think that the probability that now
well hell yeah I'm pretty sure inhaling
like I have the real I great your baby
figure I don't think that the
probability that that that
at who's behind the controls and the
spaceship is like
at an alien with us all that's going to
have a debate with the other aliens on
the board like should we aren't should
we or should we not wipe out this
is probably a fallacy that that any you
know a public computer that's running
this machine anyway who doesn't happen
same
emotions that we would have well I have
a committed by occasionally did
oh that's right you're right help
children were alright I just hope Spock
is on but when I made my side by
reference that was cookie but you're
gonna have time
you know i i rly know about the class I
mean he was ago the year and you know i
mean i get back then I would not want to
in you in school and I was I'm ancient
them I'm in school and and M
what within the show Star Trek yeah
you know all the all the boys becoming
the starter kit you know that all the
boys
you always talked about the Star Trek
episode 9 1 I've never watched
but you gotta bokram then you've got a
minute yeah
up